not this bloody Halloween away from all
of the Beemers funny are you Muslim no
come here and let me tell you about yeah
yeah come I'm gonna show you candy I'm
gonna do some real Jew come in and talk
about the real Muslim Halloween come get
inside you oh ok guys so basically I've
got my little friend inside and at the
end of the video you will see exactly
how that went as a Muslim man trying to
celebrate Halloween we'll find that
after jokes aside brothers and sisters
me myself before I came to Islam when I
was young I used to celebrate Halloween
yes I just make a lot of good money
actually to be honest I still got
knocking from door to door
trick-or-treat I don't even understand
what I was saying I don't you know what
the hell it means what I know is found
give me chocolate biscuits or some money
now I thought to myself you know what if
you think about it now the whole act
within itself is Haram the whole
celebration itself I'm gonna go down in
history what it is well forget all of
that I want you guys to reflect what I'm
about to tell you guys
Halloween is something that celebrated
once a year around October end of
October people come to your door knock
on your door some of them for eggs some
of them don't you go and if you have no
clue you open the door and see a
horrifying face it's gonna take you a
bit background what the hell I wouldn't
be lying to Shaytan or Jim or like what
he does this some may react and if you
see some videos frankly where they hit
the person why because in an instant
shock it's something that you know used
to it's dark it's already scary
something you know people are scared of
dark and you're just gonna react to be
scared you know
now imagine Bob's or sisters just
imagine now in that specific moment you
have a truth of closing the door being
scared react in screaming whatever it
may be but yeah imagine brothers and
sisters every single one of us are going
to enter the grave in this grave the
Halloween's
you know just put into perspective like
a little is not Halloween in the grave
the Halloween that you're talking about
is going to be more terrified you know
inshallah for the believer is not going
to yeah but even for the video for that
instant moment all you're gonna be
innocent you don't know what's going on
you've passed away you're in your grave
and it's going to come and visit you
bunker and nakir they are going to count
and the process alum has told us that
one's going to be black and the other
one is going to be blue that's what the
color is going to be they're going to
come and you see with a laceration these
angels yes they do as they're told
they're gonna come to that you know or
hi hello it's not straight who is your
Lord what is your religion and who is
your prophet
I see and we are told that when they
come and ask a monastic somebody who
died in disbelief somebody who heard the
message of Islam and died in disbelief
they're gonna come and ask him who was
this man that was sent and he's gonna
say I heard the one half is gonna say
the hypocrite I heard this and this
people say this in this about your grave
is gonna be so tightened that your rib
cages are going to collapse on each
other and from there onwards I was a
panatela knows the severe punishments
going to follow if you are a believer
they're going to ask you and when you
answer those questions they're going to
expand expand your grave and hunger
there are definitions of different
things that's going up in the grave
brothers and sisters when are we going
to be ready when are we going to say you
know what enough is enough you know we
get scared of little things the dark
scary movies whatever it may be you want
your scary movie which is I believe you
should not even watch it it sticks in
your head that you think that little
creature that you saw there's going to
come out from somewhere and you live in
constant fear what about when a lot of
power tell us telling us munkar and
nakir
why do we not prepare ourself why do we
not pretend prepare so that we're going
to live in this mode forever if I told
you
guys you are gone you only got a little
Australia and you have to do transit
stop at Dubai when you're at the buy I
going to sit yourself okay you know let
me start a business here let me get
married here let me go do this and this
no you're gonna say I'm here for three
hours maximum let's say one day you're
not gonna do nothing why because you
know that is not your final destination
listen life is exactly like that and
brothers and sisters this is very very
key one of the scholars said they used
to ask why are you always around the
graves and you don't come and sit with
us
he said because when I sit with you guys
all you do is talk about other people
and probably when I leave with you back
by me and you remind me of this dunya
you only remind me about the dunya when
I visit the graves they do not talk
about the people need to do their
backpack me and they remind me of the
hair after Rajas verse Subhan Allah and
Allah says an ant and hakimoto careful
hat does Ultima Maccabi Tel a sulfur
Tyler moon fumaça la sal vitale moon and
also parents Allah says you are busy
with the worldly affairs and raising one
another to attain this until you reach
the graves because when you reach the
grades that death that you see is the
shred of all pleasures yeah you know
that and Allah says and when you reach
the graves
no no then you're going to know and I'll
repeat again no you are surely going to
know brothers and sisters what are we
waiting for that day the Halloween that
you're scared of you know or you know
you're out there you might see something
in etc forget this forget this well I
have some below this is nothing this is
nothing for the horrors that are waiting
and do not forget under me the
one-minute video depressing and you know
no handle allah subhana wa taala is the
most merciful the very merciful the one
who forgives and what Allah he wants
genital for those that Allah for every
single one of you guys the point and the
question needs to be are serious
do you wonder for yourself indeed
Shaitaan is an enemy and take him as an
enemy
do not be distracted with this and that
be firm in your religion and always
always have this on your tongue ready to
be laugh here up that will be this lamb
dinner won't be Mohammed is somewhere
Lally will sell him an opinion the
process Ellen would say this and he says
in his hadith that hadith that anyone
that says this that I am pleased with
Allah is my Lord and with his thumb is
my Dean and the process tell him is my
messenger he Allah wool Allah would be
enough for him or something along those
lines in the Hereafter brothers and
sisters we believe image in a world of
the unseen and the general shared in a
constant attack the consonants actually
I advise you guys to do a card in the
morning and in the evening all the time
something that I got affected by two
years ago and I went through a panel I
cannot explain to you a card is the key
thing have it on your tongue something
that's a light but heavy on the day of
judgment and I leave you with that
problem sister's hope you guys have
benefited each ala and hope that didn't
really scare you guys may Allah bless
you guys here is how it went I was
discussing on a lighter note with our
dear friend was times Allah and do not
forget your noticing was forgiven the
most merciful strife and struggle for
the sirat al-mustaqim and hamdu lillahi
rabbil alameen and like we see in the
surah in surah fatiha yeah can i what do
i yeah kind of thing you alone we
worship and you alone we ask for help
enjoy the video minute ok school
tomorrow is haram ok don't celebrate a
living yeah do you know how to win is
haram do I know how doing this all wrong
yeah yeah and you know you know I'm just
having sweets
there's nothing wrong God doesn't I'm
sure God doesn't want me not sweet yeah
yeah yeah you know I don't believe in
the literal translation of Halloween
it's just for fun way ok ok let me
explain the Mickey's for you yeah
Halloween is hard me explain this
Halloween is Haram I'm known to be a
Haram police oh you see what you're
doing ends with Haram and what I'm doing
starts with Haram Haram police Halloween
is Haram
so what do you think I'm gonna do to you
now and knowing you celebrate Halloween
tell me give me some sweet yeah yeah I'm
gonna use them so you wait here I'm
gonna I'm gonna
don't go anywhere I mean I really I'm
gonna give you good sweets okay
this is you bloody Virginia